welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I'm Benjamin
Dixon host of the Benjamin Dixon show
from the looks of David's Instagram
timeline David is vacationing in Paris
and so have a great time David thanks
for having me let's get right to the
stories at hand this morning Wednesday
morning Nancy Pelosi convened our is
convening depending on when you're
watching this an emergency meeting on
the question of impeaching President
Donald Trump now before we get into many
of the details as to this particular
example or this particular case of
impeachment let's discuss really quickly
the house's role because I see a lot of
people who are repeating the same
talking point that Nancy Pelosi is
repeating ironically enough that it has
to be bipartisan before she makes a move
but that's not the case in the actual
technical sense the the house of
representatives their job is to one
begin an inquiry to have the Judiciary
Committee convened over it and then
three draw up articles of impeachment
and those articles of impeachment only
require a simple majority so the
Democrats have what they need in the
House of Representatives to begin the
impeachment and inquiry as well as draw
up full articles of impeachment now
there needs to be a supermajority in the
Senate of course and there's absolutely
no way that that's going to pass with
Mitch McConnell being with Republicans
being in power and Mitch McConnell being
the leadership in that body but does
that mean that the Democrats should not
go ahead and attempt to hold the
president accountable because let's be
sure if if any Democratic president had
done a single thing that Donald Trump
has done even the appearance of getting
assistance from a foreign nation and it
does not matter the details let's be
sure it does not matter any details but
the appearance of getting assistance
from a foreign nation and and we can set
that aside because according to Muller
it doesn't look like there's a lot of
meat on those bones so to say but then
there is a question of obstruct
obstruction of justice there's a clear
case of obstruction of justice so much
that Republican
representative Amash has come out in
favor of it and so I just want to be
sure before we continue this
conversation that that you understand
that the moment a Democrat becomes
president again Republicans will take
the smallest thing and impeach that
president okay
that being said here's Nancy Pelosi and
and she's in an interview with Mika
Brzezinski from Morning Joe and this is
what she had to say in response to
representative Amash a--'s stance the
Republican who has come out in favor of
impeachment take a listen Justin Amash
his position on impeachment he's tweeted
more today he's come right back at the
President does it it doesn't fit the bar
for bipartisan support for impeachment
well my personal support from
Pietschmann has to be in the Senate yeah
in terms of congressmen imagine his
voice speaks to the silence of so many
other all the other Republicans not to
hold this president accountable for the
oath of office that he takes to protect
and defend the Constitution respecting
the co-equal branches of government so
much may be one voice but the fact that
is in the absence of other voices it
speaks very loudly so I'm sorry it looks
to me that Nancy Pelosi is is doing
everything that she can to avoid
impeachment because that's not an excuse
right what that what the Senate does you
know she's trying to say unless we can
guarantee a conviction right a
conviction on the articles of
impeachment that the house would draw up
unless we can guarantee a conviction and
which work would require bipartisanship
then she's not going to do it but what
does that say about American democracy
when the body that is responsible for
holding the president accountable is
afraid to do so because of political
reasons right she's going to say in the
next clip that it's not about politics
but clearly she's avoiding impeaching
Donald Trump at least drawing up
articles of impeachment and passing them
in the house she's avoiding that because
she doesn't think she has the politics
the PAS the political capital or or the
the majority that she needs in the
Senate and she believes that it's going
to backfire
right so those are clearly political
calculations and so she's doing the
exact opposite of what she's saying
she's doing but that's nothing new
that's politics 101 but take a listen to
the second clip in her response to
Micah's a very direct question so
doesn't it pour more pressure on you
that a conservative Republican says the
threshold for impeachment has been met
no no well we have to we're not this
isn't about politics it's not about
passion it's not about prejudice it's
not about politics it's about patriotism
and it's about the presentation of the
facts so that the American people can
see why we're going down a certain path
I'm sorry but this absolutely
representative Amash his move should
absolutely put the onus and the
responsibility squarely in her lap she's
saying that it's not about politics but
as I already stated this is clearly
about politics she doesn't want any
backlash but but let's remember back
when Bill Clinton was impeached the
Republicans won everything in the
following in the subsequent election
right the problem is that Democrats do
not have the backbone that is necessary
to play the type of politics that are
going on right around us right now right
this this is a this is an extreme matter
of fact before I finish that sentence
laugh I want to make something clear
Republicans have been playing hardball
politics for a very long time they have
been cutthroat no prisoners zero-sum
game for a very long time and the fact
that Democrats are still trying to play
civility politics right the fact that
Joe Biden is coming out saying he wants
to work with Republicans shows that
there's a class of Democrats who are
extremely unequipped to fight this
present fight and this isn't a question
like I normally would do like if you
watch my show I deal with centrism
versus leftism but this has nothing to
do with that because you have a lot of
establishment Democrats who are coming
out in favor of impeachment you also
have some some leftist Democrats who are
coming out in favor of impeachment so
you have in a sense bipartisanship on
this in the divided on the left-right
the divide that exists on the left of
the spectrum they
clearly a call for impeaching Donald
Trump the evidence suggests that he
should be impeached and whether or not
you can win in the Senate is is sort of
irrelevant because Nancy Pelosi's job
isn't to worry about the Senate her job
is to fulfill her duties as the house as
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives today's program brought
to you in part by Blink accom / pakman
Linkous is a great service that i use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
B s jobs and there is a great new book B
s jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be li NK is
t.com /p a que mas